une fois que j'ai eu la victoire où j'ai
eu une heure avec un psy mais après
c'est vrai que une fois qu'on a fait
Secret Story moi après j'ai été invité
dans des fêtes grandios incroyables où
j'avais jamais vu ou croisé de la drogue
de ma vie après je suis arrivé dans des
grands appartements parisiens avec plein
de bon derrière il te ramené dans un
hôtel pour que ça se calme tellement il
y avait de foule il tombe dans une
chambre d'hôtel pendant combien de jours
alors moi pendant une semaine j'étais
vraiment sur la responsabilité de TF1
avec des gardes du corps j'avais pas le
droit de sortir de l'hôtel j'ai pas le
droit d'ouvrir les rideaux avec les
photographes en face ça a duré pendant
une semaine genre appartenais et
m'emmenait un peu comme un produit
télévisuel à droite à gauche et au bout
d'une semaine ils m'ont dit où est-ce
que tu veux qu'on te ramène et moi je
dis bah je sais pas je dis bah
ramenez-moi chez ma mère et mon descendu
donc jusqu'à chez ma mère avec des
photographes qui suivaient j'arrive
devant chez ma mère il y a des
paparazzis qui sont devant chez ma mère
de mon petit village en Bourgogne c'est
la totale et après la grosse voiture de
production repart et moi je suis tout
seul
alors que j'avais même pas gagné cette
saison là mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'engouement et ça fait un peu
le buzz et tout donc ils m'ont mis aussi
à disposition garde du corps